gotta go fast we're glad that sonic got
the redesign he deserves when the
trailer for Sonic came out everyone was
already scratching their heads gone was
the character that we know and love from
the video game and in its place was a
creepy little blue boy with a full mouth
of photorealistic Cuban teeth it's safe
to say whoever was in charge of
character design definitely missed the
mark instead of serving us a fun-loving
Hedgehog who can run faster than any
cheetah they presented us with a little
demon from the inner circle of hell
today we'll be looking at how the
creators of the film changed
Sonic's look in an attempt to salvage
the film if you look at photos of the
original Sonic cartoon
he's extremely likable he's 50% Punk
with his blue mohawk and 50% cute with
his huge unblinking eyes Sonic first
came into the world as Sonic the
Hedgehog a Japanese video game series
created by Sega the franchise was
centered around the blue hedgehog
fighting his arch-nemesis dr. Eggman a
mad scientist with a moustache so big
it's almost a character in its own
Sonic's vibrant cobalt blue color was
chosen to match Sega's logo and his
shoes were inspired by Michael Jackson's
infamous boots it was said his
personality was based on Bill Clinton
and his can-do attitude we wonder what
Hilary has to say about this Sonic
quickly rivaled Nintendo's mascot Mario
and the video game became one of the
best-selling franchises of all time
grossing a hot little 5 billion dollars
by 2014 it's gone down in history as one
of the greatest games of all time and
has heavily influenced pop culture kids
dress up for him on Halloween and
self-respecting adults continue to get
his face tattooed on their bodies some
more tasteful than others he is a total
icon and yet somehow paramount managed
to mess it up in their first try at
bringing him to the big screen as we
said before when the trailer dropped in
2019 the internet set fire with fans
going off about how truly horrified they
were with the hyper-realistic sonic in
the original design he really looked
like a prepubescent boy trapped in a
mascot suit doomed never to escape it
got so much backlash that paramount was
forced to push back the movie's release
date in a 10
to fix their horrible mistake the team
brought an animator Tyson Hess to leave
the redesign and try to make sonic look
less like a Teenage Mutant Animorph and
more like his origin thankfully they
started by changing the eyes which were
a main part of the problem in the video
game Sonics eyes were joined but for
some reason the animators decided to
separate them which made him look more
human but not in a good way in the you
would want to avoid eye contact at all
times kind of way in the redesign
however they upgraded his entire face
his eyes got bigger and more cartoony
his nose became less like a dog snout
and more like a button and his human
teeth were thankfully swapped for some
normal cartoony looking chompers though
his eyes are still separated because of
their new size they no longer look
anatomically similar to an actual
Hedgehog which really is a godsend on
top of that his eyebrows also got more
defined which allowed him to have a
greater range of expression in the first
pass Sonic had knees elbows and calves
making him have a more defined bone
structure the animation team thankfully
decided to scrap this and upgraded his
body to be more loose and compact and
less rigid and creepy in round two with
the blue they made his torso more
defined and gave him a triangular shape
with broad shoulders and a dainty narrow
waist he also appeared to have visited
the salon and got a total hair makeover
his fur became more vibrant blue and
overall a lot smoother they also seem to
get rid of the weird Tufte fur patches
that we saw in the first trailer and
made his spikes more defined to resemble
the Sega version in addition they also
decided to give Sonic back his big white
gloves instead of just making his paws
fur white he also got bigger socks and a
better pair of red kicks in the second
trailer with the upgraded design Sonic
describes himself as a little blue ball
of super energy in an extremely handsome
package we think this is a cheeky little
nod to the animation team giving
themselves a pat on the back for playing
dr. Frankenstein and going back to the
workshop to spruce up their terrifying
monster so they managed to save the
character design but did they save the
movie itself now that it's out the
reviews are in and people are giving
their two cents overall the movie has a
pretty generic plot and is overly
predictable the plot goes like this in
order to escape the villains of his
planet
sonic voiced by Ben Schwartz uses his
magical portal
and lands on planet Earth after trying
to blow off some steam by running around
a field sonic accidentally emits an
electromagnetic pulse that shuts down
the power across the Pacific Northwest
the United States Department of Defense
then enlists dr. Robotnik played by Jim
Carrey to help find the source of the
outage and it is then that he tracks
down Sonic by then sonic has befriended
the good-hearted sheriff named Tom
played by James Marsden and is shacking
up with him Robotnik invades the house
but Tom and Sonic escape the rest of the
film we see them narrowly avoiding him
while trying to track down Sonic's bag
of rings that he needs to teleport they
are able to locate them at the
Transamerica Pyramid and from there he
teleports Tom and his wife Maddy to
safety while he takes on Robotnik and
his robots after a number of harrowing
fight sequences Robotnik is taken down
and sent to a planet made of mushrooms
while sonic moves in with Mady and Tom
as their strange blue alien roommate all
in all we were not impressed by the
flick but unfortunately the after
credits scene led us to believe that
there will be a sequel in it we'll see
tails an extraterrestrial
anthropomorphic fox emerging from a
portal searching for Sonic which
suggests that the story is not over and
we wish it was if we were to assign a
grade for the sonic movie it would be a
d-plus ultimately it was full of cliches
and embarrassing attempts at being
relatable for younger audiences
lest we forget sonic did the floss dance
not once but twice which was
cringe-worthy at best on top of that
there were jokes thrown around about
Olive Garden's unlimited pasta and many
references to Vin Diesel and the fast
and furious all of which fell flat
another thing that we realized is that
there was little to no reference to the
video game world that he comes from and
we were curious as to why this was one
reason we think is that for many
children watching the film this will be
their first introduction to Sonic the
character while we get that
nine-year-olds these days probably
aren't logging all their hours playing
Sonic and Mario Kart anymore we wish
they had incorporated more elements from
its origin we think that if we had seen
Sonic not in the human world but in his
own home it may have been more
interesting while the new and improved
design did help a little in our opinion
it didn't save the film although if they
had kept the original design it would
have been a total train wreck imagine if
this media
her film would started the original
sonic completely with his lanky body and
beady little eyes it would have gone
from kind of meth - totally roasted in
his new and improved body his sassy
character works he comes off as a kind
of irreverent troublemaker with a
penchant for speed we can't even imagine
what all his fast moving sequences would
have looked like with the old design
probably terrifying it would have been
just like watching the kid from Jumanji
when he's transforming into a monkey
moving at the speed of light and dodging
bullets incredibly awkward and confusing
there is something called the uncanny
valley which the original design falls
into it's a concept that suggests that
humans like to see robots looking
human-like but only up until a certain
point at some point their humanist
becomes eerie and unsettling it's like
they're recognizable but something is a
little off usually their features are
hyper real much like Sonic's teeth in
the original design his mouth is
picture-perfect it's as if he is
constantly flossing and is some kind of
expert in oral hygiene but apart from
dentists most sets of teeth aren't that
perfect which makes us question why
Sonic's would be sure you can chalk it
up to him being an alien and maybe he
has better healthcare or something but
when it comes down to it it's just
somehow scary in the first design he
looks over animated and to humid it kind
of reminds us of that scene in stranger
things when wills mom finds his
so-called body in the lake we know it's
probably not real and that fact alone is
probably the scariest part of the show
to see something you think you know well
but it's ever so slightly altered and
heightened though over the years
computer graphics have gotten so much
better and technology has allowed for
characters to become more realistic it
appears that the engineers have still
not figured out how to not freak us out
with their creations though Sonic has to
go back to the drawing board with its
original design and came back a whole
lot cuter it still isn't our top pick
for flick we would however like to give
Jim Carrey props for his portrayal of
Robotnik though the movie was somewhat
tedious Carrie's performance peppered in
some excitement as he returned to his
roots and gave us some Ace Ventura vibes
his use of physical comedy reminds us of
him at 30 playing characters like the
mask though it was fun to see him flex
we weren't overly impressed by james
marsden character he was your average
middle-aged white man
trying to do the right thing in a small
town we don't know about you but we're
tired of this character and it feels as
though we've seen it about 1 trillion
times in our opinion when the team
decided to change Sonic's CGI they
should have changed the plot and the
characters as well we would have liked
to see some original content and not
just a whole movie recycling other films
and cobbling together a weak collage
paramount if you're listening don't just
rely on a name that everyone knows to
carry a film next time we'd like to see
developed characters brand new plots
that haven't been done before and CGI
that doesn't give us nightmares please
and thank you our final thought though
Sonic is supposed to be a little
speedster we think this movie is going
nowhere fast what do you think of the
new Sonic was the CG I've redesigned
enough to make a quality movie centered
on lightning-quick
alien hedgehog let us know in the
comments and subscribe to the things for
more
[Music]
you
[Music]